stepana kert die ehemalige Hauptstadt
bergkarabachs ist eine Geisterstadt wir
fahren in einem Konvoi begleitet von der
aserbeidschanischen Polizei durch den
Ort am Straßenrand ausgeschlachtete
Autos die Häuser verlassen ein
ausgebleichtes Plakat von Wladimir Putin
wie ein Symbol dass die einstige
Schutzmacht die Bewohner nicht gerettet
hat wir wüssten gerne ob noch Armenien
Stadt sind und wenn ja wie es Ihnen geht
aber aussteigen dürfen wir nicht die
aserbeidschanischen Behörden haben
andere Pläne mit uns was hier jetzt
passiert ist ein Pressetermin in Areal
wo bis vor 12 13 Tagen noch Armenia war
zeig sozusagen nicht Stepan ktranken die
als erstes die Stadt sondern man hat uns
jetzt hier aufs Land gefahren den
ehemaligen Flughafen und zeigt uns
eineplantage der Grund dieses Termins
wirdell K die aserbaidschanischen
Behörden wollen uns beweisen dass die
Armenier mit Drogen gehandelt haben dass
hier Kriminelle die Kontrolle hatten
Aserbaidschan so die Botschaft hat hier
wieder für Recht und Ordnung gesorgt wir
wollen wissen wie die Situation für die
Menschen ist die noch in Stepanakert
sind wir hören ein paar Armenier
befinden sich noch in Stepanakert was
hören sie denn
darüber ich kann das nicht kommentieren
ich war noch nicht dort meine
Hauptaufgabe liegt hier
Ortswechsel auf die andere Seite der
Grenze sie war bis vor wenigen Tagen
noch in steepana kehrt als eine der
letzten flieht Christine balayan mit
ihrem Mann nach Armenien unser Team in
Erwan trifft die 45jährige die bei
Verwandten untergekommen ist 34 Jahre
hat sie in Stepanakert gewohnt diese
Kiste ist das einzige was sie aus ihrem
alten Leben mitnehmen
konnte mich den Friedhof zurückzulassen
es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als das es
ist für mich nicht einfach ein Friedhof
dort liegt mein Vater der dieses Land
befreit hat und zwar für
mich in den letzten Tagen erzählt
Christin seien die Armenier aus den
umliegenden Dörfer nach Stepanakert
geflohen und hätten auf dem Hauptplatz
der Stadt geschlafen es waren chaotische
Zustände alle hatten Angst vor den
aserbaidschanen sie fahren durch deine
Nachbarschaft schauen dich an und Gren
sich die
Hände sie mein jetzt sind wir hier die
echten Besitzer und wir werden sagen wie
es
weitergeht wie soll man so
leben aserbeidsan hat mittlerweile eine
un missission nach stepanakeht gelassen
die keine Informationen über Gewalt
Zivilisten gefunden hat doch an dem
Bericht gibt es massive Kritik weil die
UN erst nach der Massenflucht nach
bergabach gelassen
wurde
präsidentot Selbstbewusstsein unter
seiner Führung hat Aserbaidschan ganz
Bergkarabach zurückerobert und damit ein
nationales Trauma
bewältigt in Bergkarabach führt uns das
aserbeidschanische Militär in eine
unzugängliche Gegend bis vor zwei Wochen
war hier noch Krieg unser Ziel ein
Bunker den die Streitkräfte
zurückerobert haben die Offiziere machen
uns klar keine Interviews und gefilmt
werden wollen sie auch nicht im Bunker
Verwüstung die Luft ist stickig und
feucht es riecht nach
Exkrementen das aserbaidschanische
Militär beobachtet jeden unserer
Schritte ganz
genau W Sie uns hier diesen Bunker
zeigen Filmen mit dem Handy das Filmen
wirkt wie ein
Einschüchterungsversuch was sie mit dem
Material danach machen wissen wir
nicht nicht weit vom Bunker entfernt
präsentiert man der internation Presse
einen ehemaligen armenischen
aussichtsposten der Unterstand der
Schützengraben alles wirkt wie eine
Filmkulisse also relativ gut sichtbar
hier am Wegesrand platziert ein
armenisches armeetagebuch mit Einträgen
ich kann das leider nicht lesen das ist
auf armenisch man kann nur sehen der
letzte Eintrag ist vom
2882023 und danach hören die Einträge
auf in berkarabach herrscht eine
gespenstische Stimmung vor allem auf dem
latchin Korridor über den vor wenigen
Tagen über 100.000 Armenier ihre Heimat
verlassen haben von ihrer dramatischen
Flucht erzählen uns nur die Dinge die
Sie unterwegs zurückgelassen haben Dauer
präsent ist das Militär und die
Polizei in der bergigen Gegend verlieren
wir unsere Kolonne plötzlich macht unser
Auto nicht mehr mit wir müssen auf ein
Taxi umsteigen und treffen auf den
aserbaidschanischen Fahrer Mail
bayamov er ist vor dre Monaten aus Baku
in das 2020 zurückeroberte latschin
zurückgekehrt er lädt uns zu sich nach
Hause ein seine Frau besira bereitet
gerade Gebäck vor vor 30 Jahren seien
sie von hier vertrieben worden von den
Armeniern ihr Haus wurde zerstört die
Wut auf sie ist groß immer
noch wir konnten nichts mitnehmen nur
unser Kind und ein bisschen
Kleidung Kleidung nur
Kleidung keine Tische keine Stühle keine
Möbel
nichts wir fragen sie ob sie die
riesigen Flüchtlingstrecks vor ein paar
Tagen gesehen haben nicht weit von ihrem
Haus und ob sie Mitleid haben mit den
Armeniern die jetzt wie sie damals ihre
Heimat verloren
haben nein nein das ist nicht
vergleichbar mit uns wir wurden damals
aus unseren Häusern rausgeworfen sie
haben unsere Häuser
beschlagnahmt wir haben sie nicht
rausgeschmissen sie konnten bequem in
Autos fahren und wir haben sie auch noch
mit Wasser und Essen versorgt
besira und Mail bayamov können sich ein
Zusammenleben mit Armenien nicht
vorstellen sagen sie uns eigentlich ein
die Armenier und aserbeidschaner das
gleiche Schicksal von Flucht und
Vertreibung doch der Konflikt kommt
nicht zur Ruhe zu unversöhnlich stehen
sich die beiden Völker gegenüber zu groß
ist der gegenseitige Hass in der
verlassenen ehemaligen Hauptstadt
bergkarabachs ins depana keht steht
schon jetzt ein Schild mit dem ischen
Namen hier heißt die Stadt nun ganz
offiziell rranken
die